what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
finally have
the falcon and the winter soldier
episode 3 with the introduction
of baron zemo and spoiler alert if you
have not seen it yet
sharon carter there is a lot to talk
about and i will be doing a
full breakdown going over each shot all
the easter eggs and all the things that
you need to know that'll come out
tomorrow so be on the lookout for that
but in this video we're going to talk
about that very
unexpected twist ending what it means
and what
repercussions it's going to have for
future episodes of the falcon and the
winter soldier
and talk about a sharon carter theory
that me and chris from cosmic culture
came up with which if we are right about
could change the way you look at the
falcon and the winter soldier and
sharon carter what has she been up to
and how did she come to be
in such high power in madrapore this
city
where there are no laws i'll break down
what she's been up to and talk about who
she might be now the first part of the
ending to episode three of the falcon
and the winter soldier
is of the flag smashers specifically
carly becoming a lot more extreme
so extreme that she actually ends up
killing at least
six people of the grc with explosives
and this is actually a big surprise to
dovich the flax masters are supposed to
be
about bringing unity to the world
breaking down the barriers smashing the
flags where people don't have individual
identities but all
exist as one they are supposed to be
trying to help the world but carly is
straight up murdering people now
dovich was very shocked when the
explosion went off stating that there
were still people in there
but carly's reasoning was this is the
only language that these people
understand
so by killing these people she is
sending a message to the grc
letting them know that she means
business meanwhile in the final scene
we find zemo bucky and sam in riga
latvia here zemo is talking about
sokovia
sokovia as we know now from one division
is where wanda and pietro were from
they also revealed this in avengers age
of ultron and zemo was talking about the
fallout of what happened in avengers age
of ultron how the country was basically
taken up into the sky
and dropped zemo was also himself from
sokovia
and he talks about what happened to it
after age of ultron basically it's not
even a country anymore its surrounding
countries took over it pretty much
immediately after age of ultron but as
he's talking about this we can see that
bucky actually starts to get a rather
curious and interesting look on his face
and he's a little bit bothered by it
he tells sam and zemo that he's going to
go for a walk
he leaves zemo and sam and as he goes
for a walk he discovers some
kimoyo beads you may recognize these
beads from black
panther they're used for a number of
different purposes they could be used
for medical reasons t'challa uses a
kimoyo bead to stabilize everett ross's
wound in black panther
they can also be used as communication
beads to talk with another they can
be used to display holograms along with
much more and they're actually developed
from vibranium so they're pretty
distinguishable beads that bucky happens
to find
on the ground now in this case we can
hear the beads beeping
they're being used for a very specific
purpose and that specific purpose is to
get bucky's attention
someone from wakanda wants to talk to
him and he knows that because he finds
the beads
he follows them until he eventually
reaches a point to where he knows a
wakandan is around him he then states
you drop something then before even
seeing the person as he turns around he
says
i was wondering when you were gonna show
up and as he turns we see a wakandan
woman and she says
i'm here for zemo now this wakandan
warrior is
io we actually first saw her in black
panther she is akoyi's second in command
and she protects king t'challa
she also fought in avengers infinity war
and as she said she's there for zemo now
this actually ties into something that
sam
said to bucky earlier on in the episode
right before zemo broke out when sam was
explaining to bucky how dangerous zemo
was he said that zemo blew up the u.n
he killed king t'chaka and framed bucky
for it
he then says did you forget that do you
think the wakandans forgot about it
it's a rhetorical question they didn't
and it is very clear by this final scene
that they did not
in fact forget about it they have
figured out that bucky is indeed
with zemo and they plan to kill him zemo
killed their
king king t'chaka they want revenge they
want zemo to pay for what he has done
not only did he kill their king but he
is also responsible for a great deal of
chaos that followed if t'chaka was never
killed and he was still the king of
wakanda then when killmonger came
the events probably would have played
out a little bit differently killmonger
never would have become the black
panther and wakanda wouldn't have been
slightly torn apart for a bit so this
isn't exactly going to be easy for bucky
here
bucky loves wakanda he was the white
wolf in wakanda and the people grew to
love him as well
but they're going to want revenge but
obviously bucky needs zemo alive
this is definitely going to play a
pretty significant role
in falcon in the winter soldier episode
4 and maybe even future episodes after
that as well we definitely have not seen
the end of ayo
and perhaps more wakandans could show up
or we may even get to see wakanda again
bucky did tell the therapist that he
wanted peace and the only piece that he
really felt was at wakanda so it may be
that he returns to wakanda at the end of
the series
so that is the ending of the falcon and
the winter soldier episode 3
explained and now to talk about sharon
carter after seeing her in many
different trailers she finally made her
appearance
and she did it with style in fact she
did it with a little
too much style we find out that after
the events of captain america civil war
where she helped steve rogers get his
shield back and help sam get his wings
back
she directly violated the sokovia
accords and she didn't have any of the
avengers to actually help her
she had to go on the run because she was
now wanted she made her way over to
majarport a city where there are no
laws but did you notice something
particular about her
she seems to be doing rather well for
herself in madrapore she has a really
really nice place seemingly a really
nice club and she talks about the
clients that she has
and then in the shipping yard after dr
nagel dies
she tells the lady with her we've got a
big problem
actually a couple of them i'll tell you
in the car let's go
now she seemingly has a problem because
dr nagel died but the question is
why would this actually be a problem for
her the only way that this would be a
problem for her is if she was somehow
involved with the super soldier serums
being developed which would then beg the
question
of why is she involved and here's where
my theory comes in it is anticipated
that thunderbolt ross could be behind
a lot of what is happening ever since
the incredible hulk he has been
infatuated
with the super soldier serum we do know
that he is going to be making an
appearance in black widow in which there
is going to be super soldier serum
involved in that movie as well
so what if thunderbolt ross actually
made a deal with sharon carter to come
home
and pardon her of all her offenses
against those kovi accords
what if the deal was to get the super
soldier serum and deliver it back to him
a super soldier serum that actually
works because that's what ross has
always been after
and perhaps this is a deal he made with
sharon carter bring him the super
soldier serum and she can return home
and be pardoned of all her crimes
after all thunderbolt ross does have the
power to do that and the other problems
that sharon carter could have been
talking about were the fact that zemo
sam and bucky were tracking everything
down trying to get rid of the super
soldier serums that are left and super
soldiers
this is clearly bad news for her if she
needs the serum especially to get back
home
now of course this is just our theory at
this point in time
only time will tell if this ends up
being true but she did seem pretty
desperate to see her family again she
said she's been on the run this entire
time
hasn't spoke to her dad her mom they
don't know where she is
and desperate times and situations make
people do desperate things
but we'll have to wait and see what is
really happening and what her problem
really is until the next episode or
maybe a few episodes more
but in the meantime let me know what you
think about this theory in the comments
down below and what did you rate this
episode of the falcon and the winter
soldier
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on my full breakdown coming tomorrow
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof